france à présent le parlement sur le
point de renforcer la protection des
lanceurs d'alert le texte doit être
soumis à un ultime vote dans l'après
midi au sénat une loi pour conforter le
rôle de contre-pouvoir des lanceurs
d'alert on va avoir tous les détails
avec dilma rosie notre reporter qui nous
a rejoint sur ce plateau faux guilmain
bonjour bonjour olivier alors jusqu'à
présent les lanceurs d'alert n'était pas
protégée en france alors hop 6 1 mais de
façon très imparfaite en fait il ya déjà
une loi en la matière la loi sapin 2 qui
a été adoptée en 2016 celle notamment
qui consacrait endroit le terme lanceur
d'alert sauf que cette fois elle avait
notamment un défaut majeur à l'imposer
que le lanceur d'alerté face d'abord un
signalement en interne avant
éventuellement de contacter les
autorités compétentes ou même d'avertir
le public à leur signalement en interne
cela voulait dire qu'un salarié qui
était témoin au hasard d'une fraude
fiscale devait d'abord avertir son
employeur qu'il était au courant que ce
dernier était dans l'illégalité alors
vous vous imaginez bien olivier que pour
le lanceur d'alert c'était se mettre
directement en porte à faux et risquer
des représailles et c'est entre autres
ce à quoi le nouveau texte devrait
remédier alors l'imac est ce que cette
nouvelle loi on va changer alors déjà
olivier le lanceur d alerte va donc
pouvoir s'ils le désirent faire un
signalement directement auprès de la
justice ou des autorités compétentes
c'est là la principale avancée la
divulgation publique est elle aussi
possibles restent très encadrées par
exemple si un signalement en externe n'a
pas été suivie d'effet après un certain
délai ou s'il ya un danger grave et
imminent de plus le lanceur d'alerté ne
sera pas poursuivi pour les dégâts que
ces révélations pourraient causer et
surtout il est également mis à l'abri en
cas de vol ou recel de documents en lien
avec son alerte et ça c'est très
important aussi olivier tout simplement
parce que pour prouver ses dires un lord
alerte s'appuie en général sur des
documents sur des bases de données qui
sont la propriété de l'entreprise dans
laquelle il travaille alors
qu'actuellement ces documents ils les
vols ce qui constitue en soi un délit
l'entreprise mise en cause ne se prive
pas en général d'attaqué sont employés
sur ce motif pour tenter de faire
pression sur lui ç'a donc en théorie
avec la nouvelle loi s'est terminée le
lanceur d alerte de plus n'a plus à être
directement témoin d'une violation du
droit il peut signaler des faits qu'on
lui a rapporté il est accompagné dans sa
démarche par le défenseur des droits il
bénéficie en outre d'un appui financier
pour ses fans justice et sont protégés
également les personnes ou associations
qui l'ont emporté de l'ale tout ceci
olivier devra donc largement facilité
les signal et du coup la france est ce
que c'est la seule à à se doter d'une
telle loi alors non pas du tout allait
bien en fait toute l'europe s'y met tout
simplement parce que cette loi adoptée
aujourd'hui eh bien c'est la
transcription en droit français d'une
directive européenne de 2000 19 à noter
que les états membres avaient jusqu'au
17 décembre 2022 21 pour se conformer à
ce texte aucun n'a respecté les délais
et pour le moment une nouvelle loi en
faveur des lanceurs d'alerté n'a vu le
jour que dans une poignée de pays merci
beaucoup guillemin pour toutes ces
précisions une lanceuse dallaire
d'ailleurs qui sera avec nous à 8h en
plateau pour en parler